hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to Disney
Princesses they represent everything
kind metha chol powerful and beautiful
and absolute clickbait you what ever
mentioned online this is my feeble
attempt to cash in on that why do we
love to talk about them so much they
represent what we want to be but have
been criticized often for either being
too flawed or too perfect maybe that's
one of the reasons we like to write
conspiracies about them fan theories and
gossip that often can't proven to be
true or false
it's humanizing to think there's secrets
behind those flawless smiles that might
actually make them more complex or even
morcín blogs forums and fan sites have
gone nuts coming up with their own
reasons on why certain things are the
way they are and truth be told I've come
up with a few as well this is a
combination of them to give a new point
of view on the fairy tales you thought
you knew so well and we're gonna look at
the top 11 of them here today why top 11
because I like to go one step beyond so
sit back and enjoy the top 11 Disney
Princess conspiracies
no Marlin Beauty and the Beast takes
place in no chat doll we know that the
story is set in France despite only one
person having a French accent but why
would they all be speaking English
anyway one conspiracy at a time but
where exactly in France is it the theory
is that not only could it possibly be
around no trade um but maybe it all
happened at the exact same time
Quasimodo and Frollo were having their
um adventures my first thought is that's
false because mildred on seems like a
giant place full of tall buildings and
bells village seems very quaint and
small but doing research that does seem
to be not only quite a few towns over
the years but also mountains and
landscapes very similar to the ones they
explored seeing how the beast was
transformed and people seem to have just
forgotten or ignored him as their prince
maybe this gave a chance for the church
to take over and Frollo to rule help
it's established at the end of the
gargoyles aren't part of Quasimodo's
imagination maybe they did something to
piss off the same in chanceries that
transform the beast but still there's no
hard evidence unless at one point Belle
had her nose so deep in a book that she
just accidentally walked by the bell
tower - holy shit there she is
I'm not kidding that's a real scene from
Hunchback of Notre Dom when Quasimodo is
singing the song out there you can
clearly see Belle walking by we may not
have an official we're from the creators
but that's a pretty big clue right there
so does Belle live in no trade on let's
hope so because about between Frollo and
the beasts would be friggin awesome
you
number ten lilo and stitch is namesake
okay
I know lilo isn't technically a princess
but I think she dressed up like one or
TV show does that count I'm saying that
counts
not much thought has really been given
to the meaning of the names that these
characters have stitch is a weird enough
name for an alien Nani is a basic term
for beautiful and well there's guy named
bubbles we're not exactly gonna
interpret much from how they're called
but looking a little deeper you'll
discover that lilo is actually a
Hawaiian term having two definitions
generous won or lost generous one is an
obvious meaning it's a Disney movie and
she can obviously be very nice but lost
obviously has a connection to the laws
of her parents and how her family or
what's left of it is drawing further
apart even stiff goes into the middle of
the night repeating the word over and
over okay I guess that guy can ex but so
what
well when stich enters their lives
things get more hectic but he also
Maja's to help their connection and what
this dish mean but to patch things up
bring two separate pieces closer so the
actual title to lilo and stitch could
just as easily be called lost and pulled
together this subtly gives a deeper
relevance to what was seemingly a simple
title so we see maybe there's more than
a name than we thought with this movie I
guess that's interesting but we still
don't know why the Warner Brothers have
a sister who's just randomly named odd
oh my God my life makes sense
no we're not Mulan is actually more than
a princess there's an ongoing argument
among Disney fans about whether or not
Mulan should be featured in the Disney
Princess lineup not because of her
character or anything like that but
because she's never in any way given
that title she wasn't born into royalty
married into royalty the most she did
was hug an ever maybe his royal and is
rubbed off making her a princess
nevertheless anytime there's a selling
of toys or he need all the princesses
lined up she's always in there so why
would they showcase something that
clearly didn't happen
well one by many respects does what none
of them have ever done saving an entire
nation countless numbers of people and
doing it all in a non-conventional way
despite that cove caused her great
dishonor because of this the Emperor of
China vows to her and it's indicated
that this never happens he even offers
her a position by his side but she turns
it down so from her accomplishments and
a bow from someone as high up as the
emperor in many respects Mulan is even
greater than a princess she's the
protector of an entire nation and what
is well T but the protector of one's
land and people so in the same way
Elsa's often in the lineup even though
she's technically a queen or Pocahontas
is in the lineup even though she's
technically a Chiefs daughter
what isn't promoting herself letting
people call her princess
she's demoting herself because such acts
offered her even higher authority but
let the values that Disney likes to
market as princessy are still there so
it kind of makes sense to have her in
the wild so is she a princess well to
quote ob1 for almost certain point of
view in fact she shouldn't just be
princess she should be dead center with
a sword in her hand leading the damn
army to away from the left a man a
little baby is all grown up and saved in
China
number eight jasmine inspires a secret
identity a good chunk of the story
Aladdin is about the power of appearance
you see Princess Jasmine pretends to be
a peasant inspiring peasant Aladdin to
pretend to be a prince inspiring well
there's nobody else left right maybe not
ever notice the voice of that merchant
in the opening sounded a little familiar
no surprise it's Robin Williams who also
provide the voice of the genie but wait
why would they have him in a dual role I
mean it's funny and all but it's not
like this film is short I'm Robin
Williams talents well a theory has been
circulating that this is actually the
genie in disguise inspired by the
charade started by Jasmine to get
people's attention by pretending to be
someone else he even kind of looks like
him with a similar beard high energy and
even wearing blue however the end of the
third Aladdin movie the one that went
straight to video shows him once again
as seemingly just the merchant I guess
he waited several years to finish that
suppose it three-part story so it seemed
like there was no real connection until
the director came out recently and
announced that yes this was always the
idea the genie was telling the story
about Aladdin as the merchant it just
had to be cut out of the ending because
of time and budget restraints you notice
in the first film the merchant never
does come back so we could draw the
conclusion that the merchant at the end
of Aladdin and the lad and three is also
the genie enjoying his freedom in
disguise as you never do see the two of
them on screen at the same time and all
of it stemmed from a princess inspiring
a peasant inspiring a genie emphasizing
what was said right at the beginning it
is not what is outside but what is
inside that counts
Merson Snow White is 14 the princesses
have a knack for looking a lot older
than they really are
in fact the technical gram of the group
is Elsa at 21 yeah she's the only one
you could buy a drink for at a bar or
maybe her buy you one you know be cold
at least most of them look like they're
at least in their early 20s and while
some come close like Cinderella and
tiana or 19 and Rapunzel polka has or 18
none of them past the big two Oh some of
them look about right Ariel and Mulan
certainly seem sixteen and I guess Belle
could maybe pass for seventeen but how
the hell is no white 14 just look at the
live-action reference does that look
anywhere close to that age the thought
is that Disney want to appeal the small
girls thinking they could be a princess
but also didn't want her to seem too
also that they could imagine themselves
in the role fourteen seemed like an okay
in-between for someone to seem girlish
but also given the time period be able
to live with her prince
it's a strange choice that really
doesn't hold up today and to be honest
nobody was really buying anyway but that
is the official age that's often
announced whatever until I see a 14 year
old Snow White working at Disney World I
don't believe it
why can't you be closer to Jasmine's age
who's only a year older are you kidding
me guys how does it contrast with the
princess who all have no documented ages
whatsoever
I guess age really is just a number and
sometimes not even that
number six Bell is an outcast because
she wears blue now don't get me wrong
everything sung about her is true she
does keep to herself doesn't gossip and
reads at a time when it wasn't expected
women have you ever noticed no one else
in the town wears the color blue like at
all look at it nobody even comes close
there apparently isn't one piece of blue
cloth in the entire town why not is that
well the only are a character you
eventually see where blue is the Beast
and according to the intro he was a
selfish and unkind ruler maybe people
associate in what he wore with something
naked like if you saw someone walking
down the street with a Hitler mustache
it's not legal or anything but it's a
touch off-putting but see how was so
long ago they forgot they even have a
prince maybe they forgot why the color
blue was unfashionable too
this would explain why Belle wears it as
she clearly doesn't care what people
think of her making her match up with
the Beast all the more meaningful seeing
how they're both al casts in their own
unique way again just a theory but it
doesn't make both her and the prince of
notre Dom stand out
love
you
number five glove story so something not
very surprising is that some of the
princesses wear gloves no big shock
their boughs common and accessories
tiaras are jewelry but there's been an
interesting theory floating around out
of all the princesses only three seem to
wear them Tiana Cinderella and Belle
well okay but so what all of them have
one thing in common can you guess what
it is
none of them were born into being
princesses they had to hook up with a
prince and marry into it and strangely
enough none of the other Disney
princesses wear gloves the ones that
married into it are the only ones could
it be there's some sort of connection or
message we're not seeing is it that they
came from more hardworking backgrounds
so they hide their hands because they
think they might look too roughed up
maybe Disney is doing a subtle
commentary on touching between common
folk and higher ups or maybe they have
rocky fingers that you fire out of their
fingernails and they want to keep them
covered so that nobody suspects their
plans for world domination
okay the probable likelihood is that the
time periods these three were a part of
jazz had gloves as common accessories
even Elsa wore them a lot in her film
and she was born in royalty but she does
take them off
but only when she's Queen but only when
okay I can't connect everything
nevertheless it's an interesting
coincidence and whether or not they want
to admit to their fire shooting nails
it's entirely up to them but just know
we'll be watching
comer for the leaning tower of penis
this one goes back a long ways and yes I
did mean it that way
I'm both the poster and VA just cover of
the Little Mermaid
people swear that one of the towers
looks particularly um penetrating for
years people have been claiming that the
art is not once but twice nook in a dong
on the marketing for one of the most
famous kids films of all time is it
possible somebody just thought they
could sneak that in with nobody noticing
I guess so but there is also a theory
that the castle is based very much on a
style of architecture that well can be
rather phallic there is a naivete that
some people have when they focus too
much on a project and it's totally
possible maybe the person who put this
together just didn't notice was it
intentional who knows but for the rest
of us we've been laughing our asses off
until they finally brought the movie to
DVD and scrapped the cover altogether
was it because this image was just too
distracting and controversial hard to
say and yes I met that one too
Disney covers have changed a lot over
the years so we can't really know 100%
whatever the reason this lives on is one
of those great snickering moments you
don't want to look at but can't possibly
turn away from oh what
number three else's reason for no
boyfriend sure we see Anna gets not one
but two suitors in frozen but notice
nobody ever seems to go for Elsa and
Elsa doesn't seem to go for anybody
either this might be from an
increasingly popular theory that Elsa
could very well be a lesbian
I'm not exactly sure why she's the one
singled out after all Merida not only
doesn't get a boyfriend and brave but
she turns down everyone that's offered
to her maybe brave wasn't popular enough
or interesting enough to garner such a
theory but frozen certainly is this idea
is catching on like wildfire to the
point where there's even a hashtag
pushing for the sequel to give Elsa a
girlfriend this could mean Elsa would be
the first lesbian princess even though
again she's technically a queen but
that's not gonna stop them from putting
her in the lineup it seems to be a
healthy trend with more and more gay
characters popping up in children's
shows and movies in fact frozen arguably
already has a gay Kurt with many saying
the store owner might have been waving
to his husband in the sauna a touch
debatable but still possible I guess we
can't know too the sequel comes out if
well Elsa does too
we don't even know if they'll address a
love interest in the next one chances
are they can milk this baby's popularity
for several sequels they can take as
long as they want with this but with
tons of fans and even her voice actress
adele dazeem saying she's on board for
it this might be a theory that could
possibly hold some frozen water
number two Hercules and Ariel are
related how the hell is that possible
they don't even take place in the same
time periods well knowing the incredibly
factual scientific research of Greek
gods and mer people it can be concluded
that their lifespans can be debatably
long even if that were true though how
these two have any connection you see in
Greek mythology / Keeley's father Zeus
is brother to another god named Poseidon
seen here in Disney's very odd rendition
Poseidon has many many sons and one of
them is named that's right try a
different Triton perhaps it'd be a
pretty big coincidence seeing how both
of them have mystical powers connected
to the living underwater whether it's
the original Triton or a name just
passed down through the family there is
definitely a relation and Triton seventh
daughter is of course Ariel because of
this that technically means Hercules is
Triton's first cousin and Ariel is
Hercules cousin once-removed
yeah it strange to think that these two
might actually have some blood between
it's made even stranger when you
consider the fact that Hercules also
seemingly existed at the same time the
hyenas killed Skaar in the Lion King
this could all just be coincidence but
for Disney conspiracy nuts like myself I
like to think maybe people are keeping
it more in the family we think
and the number one Disney Princess
conspiracy is the ship from frozen is
connected to tangled and the Little
Mermaid yeah you're probably sick of
seeing this one everywhere but the fact
is it's still a pretty damn good theory
the ship carrying the parents of Elsa
and Anna is seen sinking at the
beginning of frozen the first part of
the theory indicates that they were
heading to Rapunzel's coronation which
was happening at the end of tangled why
jump to that conclusion well on top of
Rapunzel attending Elsa's coronation the
timelines actually do match up after the
death of the parents frozen skips three
years the exact amount of time in
between frozen and tangulls release
dates but where's the Little Mermaid
coming well or Armada was also a Hans
Christian Andersen's story like Snow
Queen which frozen is based on Little
Mermaid is set off the coast of Denmark
which means it's totally possible that
the graveyard of ships seen in both the
opening and ending of the movie could
very well contain the ship that had Elsa
and his parents on it it's unlikely it's
the one she's searching through her the
one that the Prince steers at the end as
their designs are very different but
it's not implausible to think that all
her treasure hunts maybe she did come
across the very same one again even
though there's no conclusive evidence of
any of it it does seem totally possible
and when you throw in Hercules in Lion
King being connected as well that's five
universes you would swear have nothing
in common all subtly connected crazy you
say maybe or maybe it's the best Disney
Princess conspiracy ever devised or
maybe it's crazy but maybe it's the best
Disney Princess conspiracy ever devised
or maybe we all just have too much time
on our hands that's probably not it I'm
the Nostalgia Critic I remember it so
you don't have coming next week it's the
fam requested Jem and the Holograms the
cinematic betrayal of the 80s cartoon
but you can see it now under vessels ad
free early access just $3 a month to see
tons of people's videos early as well as
a bunch of other extra features check it
out and get the early students